GUEST SPEAKER 1: So the
original idea that we had
was to have music
and lecture that
was triggered by when you
got within a certain distance
of it, it would just
turn on and start going.
But we had some problems
with triggering this
upon coming close enough.
So this is the LED
lights that dance
to the tempo of the music.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: And one of
the cool things that we do
is actually use
another environment
as well in conjunction
with our Arduino.
It's called Processing.
So it's another
environment that allows
you to integrate with other
software on the computer--
[CLICK]
--any MP3 that you have.
So depending on
the frequency, you
can assign a bass or a treble.
And so that's what
assigns to each pin.
And so it's a really
cool thing to know
that there's other environments
that work alongside Arduino.
And we figured that
within a couple hours
and I think it
worked out nicely.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: And then
along with the light show,
there's also letters for MIT.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So we're
going to be playing "Back
in Black," in honor of Tony
Stark, an alumni of MIT.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUEST SPEAKER 3: It goes
on for three minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: It does.
[MUSIC - AC/DC, "BACK IN BLACK"]
[SINGING] Back in black.
I hit the sack.
I've been too long,
I'm glad to be back.
Yes, I'm let loose
from the noose,
that's kept me hanging about.
AUDIENCE: Are the two different
colors of lights [INAUDIBLE]??
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah, they are.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah, they're--
so you could set those
values differently.
Also, you could slice it up to
more frequencies and ranges.
We almost had the
sensor working.
It's just you need to have
the processing language.
It doesn't have
all the libraries
that the Arduino
environment has,
so that's why the
sensor wouldn't work.
Or you could also
try to create--
next stage had the Arduino
run a processing file
and activate the communication
between both softwares.
So that would be the next stage
to get actual sensor working
on Arduino.
And then run the
processing environment
that runs Arduino again.
AUDIENCE: Due to the
processing environment,
is the sensor for the sound
or is there a sound sensor?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: No.
So we have code that
slices the MP3 there.
So that's where the
slicing code is.
And the processing
has libraries where
you do Arduino dot this
function, and Arduino library,
and it runs it.
AUDIENCE: I see.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah.